i'm steve kitty i'm a professor of
ethnicity race and migration
american studies and history and i'm
director of yale center for the study of
race indigeneity and transduction
migration
which has helped to support this event
the ritm center at yale
exists to help develop and draw
attention to urgent work related to race
indigenous transnational migration and
we're grateful for our amazing
colleagues and collaborators and indeed
all of you
let me thank um
my professor professor lisa lowe and the
organizers of this event for the
gathering let me thank the panelists and
others who travel to be here
and of course our center staff including
nicole edwards and maggie katz who
helped with many of the behind the
scenes logistics to make all this happen
here in this windowless space enclosed
by cement and steel and wood
we're bubbled in the kind of
architectural membrane it seems to me
that can too easily blind us to where we
actually are
so i'll remind you that new haven has
long been home
to mohegan mashituck at pequot eastern
pequot scaticoke golden hill pogoset
niantic quinnipiac and other algonquin
speaking peoples and they were
surrounded not just in this room but out
in the rainy outdoors by patterns of
violence but also patterns of creative
survival and persistence every day
for me our location underscores the
importance of corroding
the seemingly impermeable modernist
walls here
and the gothic walls of other university
spaces we've been looking forward to
this event for a long time thanks so
much for coming i'll now turn this over
to elizabeth
elizabeth
thank you so much uh steve for that
introduction i'd also like to thank you
in the center for the study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
for all of your generous support for
this event in particular to nicole
edwards maggie katz and the ritm staff
for their work in making arrangements
for the visitors
i also have to give a huge thank you to
my colleague lisa lowe
for really making this possible
and for doing uh just all the organizing
behind the scenes and thank all of you
for coming um we have over 120 other
people tuned in virtually and counting
um so i just really want to thank all of
you for joining us for this conversation
i'm elizabeth hinton i'm a professor of
history african american studies and law
here at yale and the author of from the
war on poverty to the war on crime the
making of mass incarceration in america
and america on fire the untold history
of police violence and black rebellion
since the
1960s and it is such an honor and a
privilege to have the opportunity to
engage with robin d.g kelly derek
carpenell and garrett felber really
among uh the best thinkers and activists
um out there today to think collectively
about liberation and how we might create
a better world it's a conversation that
has
increasingly grown more urgent
even if some of the terms and the
contexts have changed in the nearly two
years
since the murders of amman aubry brianna
taylor and george floyd i think we all
really want to know
where to go from here so we're gonna
have a conversation um
for about 15 minutes to an hour or so
and then we'll open it up for questions
those of you turning in virtually feel
free to submit your questions at any
time i'll be monitoring um the chat or
the q a and maybe i'll throw a couple in
there um during the moderated
conversation um and then when we open it
up there you'll see two microphones on
either side of the stage please feel
free to come down
and ask questions um that's really the
most exciting part of the conversation
and then after the event we encourage
you to join us um for a book signing
with any of the authors up here um but
especially derek pernal whose book i'll
talk about in a second is the most uh
recent
we have excited about this
um
thank you and uh and that that book
signing was made possible by one of new
haven's gems the um independent
bookstore people get ready book so thank
you so much to lauren and the people get
ready team for making this happen all
right let me introduce our esteemed
panelists i'll go
in order of how they're seated so
garrett felber
garrett and i go way back to grad school
we were both babies
but he is um he organized one of the
most important conferences on abolition
that has taken place in recent years the
making and unmaking mass incarceration
or moomi conference at the university of
mississippi where he taught in the
history department until last year
moomi which took place in december 2019
facilitated a cross-generational
conversation between students scholars
and activists and it was really amazing
derek and i were both there on a panel
on abolition so we know um and it was
also really important because garrett
brought you know garrett held and
unapologetically abolitionist conference
in mississippi um felber
organizes many many things but among
among those projects is uh study and
struggle which challenges
criminalization and incarceration in
mississippi through mutual aid political
education and community building uh
felber received his phd in american
culture from the university of michigan
and is the author of those who know
don't say the nation of islam the black
freedom movement and the carceral state
and the co-author of the portable
malcolm x reader with the late pulitzer
prize-winning historian manny maribel
and felber is currently with us at yale
as a visiting fellow in american studies
and the center for study for the study
of race indigeneity and transnational
migration where he has worked to
complete his next book a biography of
former political prisoner martin sostray
called we are all political prisoners
to garrett's left is derek pernell who
is this generation's most galvanizing
voice around abolition
no we all know it's true
she's uh she's a triple threat
she's a grassroots organizer she's a
lawyer and she's an author uh her book
let me just show it all to you so you
will purchase it becoming abolitionists
police protests in the pursuit of
freedom just came out last october and
once again is available for purchase
outside you can get derek or pinellas
sign it for you today and um in addition
to this powerful book which everybody
needs to read and if you're in my
african-american history survey class
you're going to be reading it
um pernell's writing has been published
widely including in the new york times
the atlantic the boston review teen
vogue and harper's bazaar
purnell received her jd from harvard law
school and has lectured studied and
strategized around social movements
across the united states the netherlands
belgium south africa the united kingdom
and australia she is currently a
columnist at the guardian margaret
burroughs fellow for the social justice
initiatives portal project at the
university of illinois chicago and
a scholar
in residence at columbia law school
and uh
finally robin d g kelly
is the gary b nash professor of history
at ucla and the greatest living
historian in america
he needs no introduction so i'm just
gonna stop there no i'm just kidding um
if i were to properly introduce
professor kelly um who i've known now
for over 20
years i can't at 20 years i'm aging us
since i was a bright-eyed 18 year old at
um nyu
i would need to take 30 minutes before
you get out
well yeah oh yeah i went to your house
when you were a kid yes because i know
you're that i don't remember you
exactly i just remember you from the
intro to black urban studies
right
um
but anyways okay so professor kelly
received his phd uh in history from ucla
and has been bringing us hit after hit
ever since from his articles and op-eds
to his 13 books including the
groundbreaking and award-winning hammer
and how alabama communists since the
great depression race rebels culture
politics and the black working class
freedom dreams the black radical
imagination
and thelonious monk the life and times
of an american original among others and
these works have illuminated aspects of
the history of social movements and
capitalist exploitation in the us and
the world that have inspired generations
of activists organizers and scholars to
struggle for racial and economic justice
so getting to have this conversation and
sit down with the three of you was
really a dream come true for me and i
hope for all of you as well um
so
abolition is a process that um in many
ways really begins in our own minds
right in our own understanding of the
world
and our political and ethical
commitments and all of you
have been doing this work for some time
and so
i'm wondering if you could each um share
with us how you came to abolition as a
politics and as a practice
and um how do you think about the
meaning of abolition i guess like how
you define
uh abolition
so we'll start with you since he was
introduced first okay
um
hi everyone can you hear me
okay um
well it's it's such a i don't know i
wiggled my way onto this panel somehow
and i'm just so grateful to be here um
and
you know i want to start by just saying
thank you to all um the incarcerated
comrades who i who i struggle with and
and learn from all the time i'm hoping
we can transcribe this conversation and
send it to them
and then also my co-panelists who um
i've learned so much from so most of
anything i say helpful today will come
from those folks
i think to begin with the definition of
abolition for me it's a revolutionary
practice
to create an egalitarian society
free of coercion and domination
that sort of obviates the need for
police and prisons and punishment
um
and i emphasize i think both revolution
and practice um because i think one of
the mistakes that we make is to think of
abolition as a set of sort of beliefs or
an identity
and it really does us no good to have
people who identify as abolitionists
right that doesn't get us free
so it's also not a destination
we don't do things and arrive at this
place
um in particular so i think it's
something we do every day and when we
stumble through it and i think
experimentation and creativity is sort
of central
for me to that practice
oh my personal journey to it um
i really was sort of politicized through
history um
really thanks to
robin's writings in particular um
freedom dreams i mean derek writes about
this beautifully in her book as well
freedom dreams for me was a whole new
road map to thinking about radical
social movements
not in terms of success or failure
but as a sort of collective dream making
process
and and i read that the same year that i
read black study black struggle and that
article
robin talked about
the classroom not being a place of love
and therefore not a place of deep
critique
and that really resonated with me at the
time because i was teaching in a minimum
security prison we were teaching uh
learning about the black radical
tradition
and he mentioned study groups
and i was like what is a study group
i've only my encounter with these
radical social movements was only
through
university and college spaces which
didn't feel like a place of of love and
deep critique and accountability
and i was for the first time in a prison
encountering that space
and that was a
a paradox or a contradiction to me like
why was i encountering this space of
love and commitment within such a
violent
um
place
so um
there was an undergraduate student at
the time who asked me my thoughts on
abolition and i spouted off some very
uninformed things about utopianism and
you know it sounds nice but how would we
ever do you know like the script that we
all sort of fall into the first time i
think we encounter abolition
and i think that script tells us
something really important a few things
one of which is that we're all sort of
performing
something that we've been normalized to
believe about the function of prisons
and punishment in society and it's
actually very helpful
in organizing to undo them because we
encounter the same set of beliefs you
know what about the murders what about
the rapists
it's utopian how would we ever create
this society
um
so i guess it didn't take me that long
to
sort of get from that place to believing
that prisons shouldn't exist and police
should not exist
um but i really think the practice of
what that actually looks like beyond
just sort of going around pronouncing
that i believe this thing
is the ongoing work of abolition um of
every day
being in touch with people inside
figuring out how to support them and to
um
to dream collectively
um i can maybe talk about that more
throughout but i think
so much of the way
for me the journey through this has been
always in sort of tension and tandem
between the prison and the university
and it's been really helpful for me to
understand the way that both of those
institutions
work to
stop collective dreaming those are
institutions that work to silo us
to venerate individual
thought and solitary thought
and not collective thought and
collective mobilization
um
so
so for me that's been the sort of
ongoing work is to figure out how
how to collectively dream and and
and understand the people who have
collectively dreamed before us because
we're so often cut off
from all the work that they've done and
that's why i think freedom dreams for me
was such a touchstone because i realized
that
we have to understand that ongoing
process of collective dreaming
oh i have a couple clips of comrades
inside to play but maybe i'll do it
after both of you go because i don't
wanna oh my not the last time yeah okay
all right
um i don't know if this works can people
just hear me at my show okay
so
one of the things when i was trying to
think of something
useful to say today was that i just
wanted
really people to hear from folks inside
who i organized with so um i'm just
going to play a couple of clips i asked
them to share a few words with you um
the first one
is from a dear comrade lawrence jenkins
he's incarcerated in washington state
just a
revolutionary organizer
farmer
artist
and the second is stevie wilson who
folks might be
familiar with as well who's incarcerated
in pennsylvania so i'll just share us
i want to speak on the importance of
political education and solidarity and
our struggle to survive get free and
stay free but first i would like to
address the shortcomings of the prison
abolitionist
movement today there is a belief that
mutual aid and general correspondence
alone will help us survive genocide and
escape torture when instead these caring
acts only help us manage and cope with
these conditions by doing nothing to
liberate us from them this approach will
only help prisoners suffer peacefully
and while assuming while assimilating
our movement into the power
establishment in which controlled the
mechanisms of state violence and
oppression the very thing that developed
mass imprisonment as a tool to displace
and dispose of entire communities
this must be met with critical
resistance and revolutionary action
it is on us abolitionists who are
sincerely committed not just not in
words but in action and practical
application
we are confronting material conditions
that must be done away with completely
we are embracing business programs and
processes that ensure autonomy
independence collective
self-determination and sustainability
these are things we've identified as
primary aims and objectives to ensure
our survival maintain our freedom and
secure our destiny and we are committed
to do this till we free us
being that we are having this
conversation in a higher learning
institution today i must emphasize the
importance of political education as
well as cultural study and why it's
needed for prisoners simply put we lost
the knowledge of what we once knew we
lost control of what we once won
uh
we lost the belief that
we can do whatever we put our mind to we
need this re-education and
re-empowerment in order to further
develop a counter culture that can be
shared with the vast movement fighting
on our behalf in the behalf of our loved
ones
against mass imprisonment racism and
oppression
we are all at different stages of
development in our journey each state
has its own laws policy and practices
each prison has its own variation to
genocide slavery and cruel and inhumane
torture but is meeting us where we are
at coming with a sincere commitment to
helping us over
to helping us
come to a level of consciousness and
ability that will help us not only meet
our basic needs but also help us achieve
our aims and objectives to secure our
freedom and grace league box taught us
about revolutionary humanism
organization means commitment and that's
what we need from today's abolitionist
movement
is there a way to turn up the volume at
all because the people on zoom are
having a hard time hearing can i turn up
the volume from here can you do it
i don't know if that will help
and if not then maybe we can post them
wherever we post that yeah
so
for those on zoom
uh
make a few comments um
uh so i think it's an opportunity uh
gary and
everyone on the panel for allowing me to
to be a part of this and to say a few
words about the abolitionist movement
the dignity itself um and i want to
begin with a quotation from angela davis
um
he says uh whenever you conceptualize
social justice
you will always defeat
charity of others you deceive the very
purpose of being that work
you are constituting them as inferior in
the process of trying them to write
to you
by saying this is a call from
pennsylvania state correctional
institution camp hill this call is
subject to recording and monitoring
by saying the abolitionist movement has
learned that without the action
of prisoners
there can be no campaigns just as a
matter of fact
it may not always be easy to guarantee
the participation of prisoners but
without their participation through the
knowledge of them and equally about
fulfill
and i i find myself getting this
uh quite often people on the outside
that they need to but they need to look
at the
prison population technical partners
and they need to uh get connected to
people inside because the only way
they're going to know what's happening
in here
really what's happening here is that you
are connected to people inside you
cannot depend upon the state to tell you
how you're treating us uh you cannot
depend upon the touch going on in here
um so it's important to be connected to
people inside i've also said before that
you are doing this work all right and
you are not connected to someone inside
of you absolutely wrong
um i think it's important for us to uh
uh be connected to one another and that
um
we have to
uh to collapse and truly collaborate
with people inside
the capacities of the people inside um
this is really important instead of
coming to the project
already forward formulated and
asking people to participate in it
they're asking you to actually create
problem create programs and create these
projects with people inside and not be
like the blc department of corrections
who actually they never ask for our
consent they're going to ask for
a lot of people out there who are doing
this work do
um and i mentioned consent because
uh quite often people outside
who are
they take action
on behalf of people inside
but they don't
ask us if that's what we want
pennsylvania state correctional
institution camp hill this call is
subject to recording and monitoring
this
problem what was in florida where there
would be issues around prison labor and
people were complaining about uh
the crews the grounds for the reason
that a particular person and uh there
were people on the ground
and who were complaining about it and
what's the prisoners complaining about
it was actually the people outside and
so the person decided to
get uh riding motors
and and eliminate the crew and then only
have two people working the other 78
people aren't expecting
[Music]
why they want to work and they want to
but they were afraid to write a good job
and so i think it's important that we
look at these campaigns and look at
these whatever we're doing
get connected to the people what are the
most affected by being candid
uh
but at the same time i said uh as far as
the movement itself this move with the
beat of the people
that the little women are winners with
the
so we need to actually also create
materials
that are accessible to the masses
this is something we struggle with
inside a lot of work is being done
academically
um and there's some people who have a
really great time in writing like they
want to be read and uh like uh ruthie
and miriam cabba obviously you know
another person on the panel they're
personal rights like
written uh red you know um and this
stuff that we can use inside and explain
evolution to the people inside um
because these are the most affected by
so there's uh
a couple things i want people to think
about you know about getting connected
thinking about consent
i want us to think about
collaboration
and um and understanding that
we need to we need to get connected stay
connected and create on-ramps for people
to be able to uh participate
particularly people inside and their
family
and think about how we can do that all
right
thank you
so i'll do a quick sorry that stevie's
was harder to hear this is speaker phone
into my computer um
just to summarize a couple of the key
points that stevie was making one of
them is to get connected to people
inside and engage in true collaboration
with them so he was talking a little bit
about
these sort of programs that are
pre-formulated outside and then come in
to sort of superimpose a vision onto
folks inside and how that sort of
correlates to the docs um
relationship and and sort of led that to
talk about consent
and how some of these campaigns that
people formulate outside and he gives
examples from florida and also colorado
with trying to eradicate the sort of
clause of the 13th amendment that people
inside were actually quite concerned
about what eliminating that clause might
do for their jobs that they rely on for
assessments for themselves and their
families so to collaborate and also
think about consent from people inside
when you're doing this sort of
organizing
and then lastly about accessibility i
think one thing that stevie always talks
about
is um
how the literature being written about
movements and incarceration from within
um
the academy is just simply inaccessible
so a lot of the work that we do together
is a translation of books into zines um
and then he was shouting out derek's
work as um an example of you know
writing the way that you want to be read
so thanks for
listening
[Music]
[Applause]
hi oh okay
there's no strings i thought it was like
strings it just comes up hi and it
doesn't okay here we go hi everyone how
are you all doing
good okay never mind um
yes thank you gary i one thing i really
appreciate about you and i first
experienced this at moomi it was the
first conference that i'd gone to where
in the in the planning there was a level
intentionality to make sure that people
were currently incarcerated part of the
conversation and so i'm just so grateful
that like you did that just now that we
were able to hear from two comrades who
are inside so thank you so much for
always making sure that when we talk
about this work we also are actively
doing that and it means so much to me is
deeply inspirational so thank you
um i also who was what was the name of
the first person who spoke lawrence
lawrence it's so interesting last night
i had a conversation with a group of
students at the graduate club who were
in the grand strategic pro-grant
strategy
grand strategy grand strategic yes
and i heard some feedback so y'all gonna
have to give me the tea later about that
program i heard some things but not
everything
but one of the students asked me a
question i can't remember it right now
they it was sort of like what am i
concerned about was one of my fears and
i shared that i was nervous about the
deep pessimistic turn to mutual aid
um in the in recent years because mutual
aid is obviously very important i think
it helps to save lives
and i also shared that i think that
the hummus the the spike and homicides
that we see in the last couple of years
were probably even higher but for the
very important interventions
that people were able to provide and pay
rent provide shelter and do makeshift
daycares to take care of each other but
i'm also nervous about the pessimistic
turn to mutual aid which is this is the
only thing that we can do and i have
some control over it and we're never
going to win the state is just going to
find some other way to shift and we have
to figure out how to you know do that
terrain so i'm going to figure out how
just to pay individuals bills i'm going
to figure out how just to make sure that
people can eat because as lawrence said
that then removes our impulse to fight
against the repression of the state
which is going to continue and so i just
am so grateful that he said that just
directly and straightforwardly and it's
a deep critique that i also share of the
movement that we have now and
yeah i just didn't anticipate that it's
not something i that
you know historically i know there have
been pessimistic moves towards
flight and you know going inward but
that was one concrete thing that's when
you said i said okay you know i know
other people are thinking about this too
all right so what were the questions
abolitionism you're in your journey
yeah yeah
yeah so that's that's complicated okay i
did write a book about this thing but
i i i don't the book isn't like i was a
reformer and now i'm an abolitionist so
that is not that that is not the book at
all i hope that that's not what i have
anyone in this room
like expects because that's not what the
book is
because no one's born a reformer
like no one came out being like i'm
gonna report reform the police where's
my bottle like no one like that's not
true for anyone what often happens is
that we're born with unexamined ideas
about the world and then we're
socialized in the institution that we
belong to to develop ideas about them me
i grew up watching cops right i still
fight with my mom because she watched
law and order svu specifically right
okay all right so
yes
i know i know no shades at least again
so yes it's very is we learned these i
didn't i actually didn't remember that
so it was literally no shade to listen
i'll tell her i'm sorry um
yeah so we're socialized right and so i
watched people in my community become
cops because they wanted to be better
than the racist cop that they
encountered and i knew my mom had a
couple of friends who were cops and i
also knew that we ran from cops and cops
chased us so i knew that when someone's
home was being
getting invaded because of social work
it deemed them to be unfaint parents
cops were right there to remove children
from homes that were deeply afraid of
them so there's all these different
touch points with policing and with
prisons and so one actually
one story i'll talk about in the book is
this campaign that i worked on to close
the jail in saint louis called the
workhouse and when i was a kid i had
known so many people to go in and out of
the work house that i thought it was a
place where you got a job like i was
like it's called the house i didn't know
that the workhouse historically or jails
where people went who were enslaved and
run away or poor and had to pay a debt
in order to secure their release and so
it took years before i understood that
oh this is a jail and people don't come
back for days or weeks or months but
again just my experiences with police
and prisons and prosecutors it didn't
automatically give me an analysis of
whether they were worthy of redemption
or could be reformed or needed to
abolish right that came through
political struggle it was so funny
listening to garrett talk about um
black study black struggle and
robin saying something about the study
groups and you're like what what's that
i remember when i first met robin he was
on the panel at harvard and he was
talking about political education
political education political education
and i raised my hand and i was like well
what do i need to read for my political
education and he was like well i can't
tell you that it's really going to come
down to the people who you organize with
because you have to read the political
materials to debate and inform the
campaign or fight that you're struggling
around and i thought that was bs i
wanted robin to give me like eight books
i wanted like a political education
starter kit and he was not about that
life i was very frustrated about it and
then i went to south africa and i
watched i watched that happen i watched
students read and debate different
political texts and how and they used
that to inform the demands that they
needed in order to fight for the
freedoms that they wanted so i was there
i was watching students say you know
our movement is about free education
because we think that education is a
tool of empowerment similar to what
lawrence just said on the call and we
believe that it will help facilitate our
fight for the land here so they were
making these broader connections between
their educational struggles struggles
and these broadly decolonial demands
that to help transform the world that
they belong to and i said this other day
i was like well i was there like
watching them read and debate sometimes
physically fight over their ideas
because
they knew that there was so much at
stake and i remember coming back to the
west and thinking about our student
demands that weren't informed about
political education and i was like
they're trying to get the land we're
trying to get a diversity office like it
was not the same like this is very very
different very very very different but
that showed me how important a political
education man how important
how important it was to be a part of a
political home and a political
organization to help spur your own
individual development but to also do
that with other people you guys are
growing and figuring out how to waste
these fights for the long term
and it doesn't directly answer like my
journey to become an abolitionist
because it wasn't linear right it
happened
like a lot of people become politicizing
social movements you sort of hear people
talking about different ideas you know
abolished borders or more diversity and
you you can't quite make sense of them
like you know that there's a broader
history of people who fight for racial
and freedom and justice but until we
start understanding the role of
political education we don't understand
that history right of people who are on
the good side
it's very different from something like
tradition where people fight for
different things according to a set of
beliefs that they think will have
propelled them towards something greater
and i was being politicized around these
different
uh
traditions
gonna kill me but i was telling this
story literally the other day too about
at his parents house
there's a picture on a wall and it's
like barack obama and tupac shakur and
harriet tubman and fannie lou hamer and
like all these amazing like black
figures in history like riding on horses
to freedom
right and i remember years ago i would
have seen a picture like that and been
like oh this is so amazing like look at
our history right and then you develop
some political analysis right especially
radical leftist political analysis and
you realize that these are all very very
different people that we like group in
together and say look at our history
right kamala harris and fannie lou hamer
very very different
very very very different you know would
not recommend one they're very very very
different right and so but we just loop
them in when we group them together as
black people and black women who are
trying to fight for a seat at the table
we miss what makes them possible and so
i was being pushed around what are these
different institutions like policing
like prisons like capitalism like all
these things i had taken for granted
even though i had different touch points
with them because i had been student
organizing since i was about 14 trying
to make sense of them alone and then
once i realized okay
i have to go through this and understand
this with other people that's why i
started developing more radical politics
simply because i was surrounded by
people who were more curious than i was
who were more courageous than i was who
more radical than i was and who were
honestly patient
you know who who weren't trying to
convert me to do something to believe
something right who are actually trying
to invite me to understand a set of
radical politics that then we can force
together so that's why i really hope the
spirit of the book is it's actually less
about this is where i was and now this
is where i am but actually all of these
touch points for different people i
encounter other organizers other
movements other ideas that help me
understand that an invitation to
understand radical politics it's much
much much more than me identifying as an
individual abolitionist which is why the
title is plural and not singular because
it's not just about my individual story
but this generation who really has been
in conversation with people in other
parts of the world and people across
time and figuring out how to get free
right
[Applause]
[Music]
that is so true and you know you really
if you don't have the book shame on you
um you really need to get it because in
some ways
um
it is both
exactly what derek has said in terms of
movement history but it also is about
the way concepts like abolition change
over time in struggle it doesn't change
because a think tank is better than
another think tank it's the movements
themselves produce certain kinds of
objects so let me let me go up and just
i took all these notes
um i i love the image this image of the
the picture see my generation yes the
pictures that you had on the wall were
like kings of africa
by budweiser right
and when you talk about like being
traumatized you know like kings of
africa that was that was like our heroes
um
it wasn't like kings of africa
anti-imperialist kings no they're
massive
exact kind of energy um
and also i just want to remind people um
that that peace black study black
struggle is a forum
it's not just my essay and in the forum
is a really brilliant
uh contribution by
derek or purnell
so you need to read the whole form even
the people who who talk really bad about
me
but it's really worth checking out
and it was a really important kind of
intervention um i really have before i
sort of answered the question i just
have to acknowledge
how important it is to be with with
these three people specifically
um because
you know
i'm i'm the elder i know that
but i'm also the student of all three
um you know and if you want
if you have to you know like i don't
want to give lists but if you have to
read three books you know that has to do
with
the struggle to try to end
the carsonal state
in state violence
you know
you read
garrett
liz
and derek's book those you know of
course
both of of liz's books you know
um these are these are really essential
texts and there's nothing like having
liz hinton as my student because he was
also my research assistant
among other things
uh but you know
i take a lot of notes
you know i learned so much from her i
learned so much from garrett you know
when garrett was working on the malcolm
x project and i was like and of course
derek so these so i'm a student of of
these three people and i'm a student of
many many people
um
you know when i think about my own
journey
i think about
the folks i learned from over the years
i've talked with the early years but
later years
um i'm a student of ellie zach kelly i'm
a student of sherry randolph who's over
there i mean sherry was was a student of
mine but i was really a student of hers
michael denning remembers those days
when a handful of us would get on the
train to come to new haven
to participate with you know all the
faculty at yale to support the union was
it for people he was like you and hazel
david montgomery
and you know so you know it's like i
learned from michael over the years so
i'm very fortunate i'm just a student so
having said that
um i'm not going to answer the question
on what is abolition
um because i think the both the
brilliant answer that that garrett gave
and everything that derek said
especially in her book
answers that question for me but i'll
say some things about my journey because
it helps to understand
how
i came to understand
abolition and so first of all i have to
begin by saying
you know
back in the 1980s
you you know no one called himself an
abolitionist
to say that you're for abolition was a
very specific thing it was the year for
the abolishing prisons and abolishing
the police
and so it wasn't an identity
so i come so nate at 18 years old i'm a
communist
okay very proud of it
um
and so
you know when you're a communist
and you're 18 you already have a view of
the world what it could be
and that view is things that we think of
as anti we call it anti-capitalist now
you know we didn't say anti-capital we
just assumed you know goes anti-capital
that the destruction of capitalism
itself season well of course we had a
state-centered state-oriented idea so he
seized the state but the most important
thing is that things like a a
transformed environment
um a fair wage
housing
transportation
ultimately the elimination of comma of
commodities you know these are the
things that we dreamed of
what's interesting about being a
communist
in the 19
basically in
1980 really to be honest 8081
um
is that we didn't
always think of the prison at least not
my circles
as like the thing that needs to be
eliminated what we did do though
is that we had a sense of what a
political prisoner was
and this goes back to the title of of
gareth's book on
martin um
sostra
um
we didn't realize
that they're all political prisoners of
course that that idea is emerging in
1976 you have a you have the development
of documents that are arguing for the
abolition of prison
so i grew up in the um the generation
that said free geronimo ji jagaprat
free sundiata
you know uh assata shakur broke out you
know but there was a free assata shakur
at some point so 70s into the 1980s
there was a whole question about
political prisoners as a separate
category
now
i'm so here's my development
um
number one
in 1988
uh i'm a brand new phd just finished i
meet um ruth wilson gilmore
who becomes a lifelong friend
she was on her way to graduate school
she actually you know she's a yale
alum in theater you know that right you
didn't know that you know that
but
so she was on her way to go to rutgers
to do a phd in geography
and she had some ideas
that blew my mind
and we weren't talking about abolition
but she was talking about the
relationship between space
prison construction
and all the violence that happens to the
land to the environment to workers um
into human beings put in cages
and she's trying to figure that out
spatially
and so we had those early conversations
are like wow you know that's amazing so
of course we maintain lifelong friends i
take my my second job which is a job at
the university of michigan and so we
have a michigan connection
liz garrett me
and they know
um so i was there 1991 to about 1994. um
eliza was there as a little baby
and so i'm there and i end up doing two
things that are significant one
i teach at a place called boysville
1992.
boysville is is a place where they
detain
kids
male
children
you know and this is the carson state
this is a juvenile detention center
and i go in there and i'm teaching and
all i see
are poets
that's all i see
a whole room full of poets
beautiful children the all black and the
couple that that next kids but black
kids or poets and i'm like
and you're in here
and they made me poetry i still have
that poetry they made laminated
poems
right and then while i'm there michigan
teaching at university of michigan i had
an opportunity to go to jackson state
and meet some of the older brothers
there
and
what do i find poets
everywhere you turn poets
and their intellectuals and their
writers and their scholars and they want
to get out
there's no reason
for them to be behind barbed wire
or to have to spend
you know
90 minutes a day or two hours a day in a
yard
and we're in the yard talking to them
right and so
my mind's sort of spinning like this is
not even
so the question of political prisoners
sort of cease to be as prominent because
you begin to realize
that there's a politics of imprisonment
you know when you find when you hear
people's stories sometimes they might
make a mistake or whatever and they end
up in jail a lot of times
it's like just petty stuff
and yet
there are people i know who are in my
class at university of michigan who do
petty stuff that's way worse and they're
not in prison
you know they go home in their bmws
you know and they're paying out-of-state
tuition whatever
um
so there's that and then
all this is swirling and then in 1994
angela davis
is participating in this conference
called race matters
and i'm also one of the speakers you
know i'm like really young
not so young anymore but you know so i'm
there margaret dyson a bunch of people
angela davis gives this speech
in the room is packed this is at
princeton this is in celebration of
of um
uh
cornell west's book
you know race matters race matters
conference
and in this speech
she says she basically gives a speech
that becomes prisons or prisons obsolete
and she says in this pack woman they're
there because she's a celebrity
they're there not because they read any
of her stuff she's like packed people
just on the rafters at princeton and she
says it is time to abolish prisons
and you could you could hear a pin drop
those people like what
and i'm there watching the whole thing
and people like you they say people say
like i was at the march of washington
they're lying you know it's the same
thing like they'll say oh no i was with
her no they weren't nobody was with her
nobody was with on that and these are
young people
and the first thing they did hand shut
up
what about the rapist
these are black people
young black students are
princeton the creme de la creme
i'm sorry yale's a creme de la creme
it's secondary
so what i'm saying is that
that was mind-blowing because i was
there i would know when i said when i
was there i was there
politically i arrived to completely
agree with her on this
and that was 1994. so in some ways
i have to give credit
not to
you know my own thinking independently
it's it's not even and i wouldn't even
say that it's entirely activism so
that's part of it
part of it is that i was fortunate to be
surrounded by thinkers and intellectuals
who thought through these things
and showed a mirror
to like what what do prisons really do
to people
between ruthie angela these kids at
boysville the folks at jackson state and
then then of course you start to read
and finally last thing is just dealing
with police
violence um so i you know just uh uh
jill nelson published his book
called police brutality came out 1999.
um and that book is as relevant today as
it is as as it was then this is you know
right
in fact it was on the eve of
um was on the eve of or no it's after
alma do diallo
around that time
um and so the point is is that that book
in that book i kind of made the case at
the very end of my essay which is kind
of a history of police violence was that
we need to abolish the police
that's 1999. i'm not the first one to
say that obviously
but my point is
that that was a huge
move
and it wasn't again it wasn't a move
from reform
to a revolutionary stance because i was
always
always
i mean i was a communist
you know i believed in socialism
and still do
but the point is is that
it's amazing how the carceral structures
are often taken for granted
we talk about the role in
reproduction of capital but not always
but but there was a belief that somehow
they could be transformed or reformed
because there's some people who need
that that we need police that we need
prisons so the leap
is huge and that's why the last thing
i'll just say about this
and that's why we have to we have to
remember
um and derek makes his point in her book
that as much as we talk about the 13th
amendment
and the 14th amendment
but the 13th amendment the clause that
says
essentially
um
you could still have slavery as long as
someone commits a crime
nobody was questioning that in you know
1865 or 66
because in fact du bois in his grand
black reconstruction was very proud of
the fact that reconstruction moved from
the prison camp
to the penitentiary that the
penitentiary was the modern iteration
the safer more humane
sort of solution to deal with prisoners
so we've made a huge leap from that
you know it's not we're not going back
to the older abolition this is a new
appalachian
and that was a product of these kinds of
struggles so
that's sort of my my journey but i just
i i stopped there you know and just
simply say
you know we have to
always
um pay attention to the institutions
that have become so normative
and that that's not just the prison it's
the family
you know there's all kinds of things we
think about that we think is normative
that those things are untouchable just
to fix them so we have to think really
hard about that so to be an abolitionist
is
to
uh
change everything as ruthie would say
and
it's to live life in rehearsal which is
also ruthie's term so i'll stop
thank you all for uh for sharing and for
those comments you know it's it's a
reminder i think as garrett said that
abolition itself isn't linear that it's
constantly evolving and that it grows
out of ideas and discussion and struggle
um
so
three of us up here are historians and i
would be remiss if i
didn't invite us to talk about history
and so um robin and garrett i'd like you
to share some of your
expertise on the history of and
struggles for racial justice and robin
we just read portions of hammer and hoe
in my
african-american history survey so the
alabama sharecroppers union has been on
my mind a lot lately and i'm wondering
if you could um
just
help us think through some lessons that
we can learn about how to organize and
sustain uh radical social movement from
the history of communist organizing in
the 30s and 40s
as well as drawing from other aspects of
your work maybe cultural forms like like
jazz and hip-hop and
garrett and those who know don't say you
introduce a concept called the
dialectics of discipline as a way to
consider the kind of simultaneous rise
of collective black resistance and
escalating state repression um
like increased reliance on solidarity
solitary confinement and maximum
security prisons
as a reaction to protest and
mobilization among incarcerated people
and um
you and in many ways all of your work
helps us see how the carceral state and
the movement to abolish it really rose
together so i guess it's a similar
question
that i'm um asking of robin and that is
what can abolitionists today learn from
the struggle of incarcerated muslim
activists in the 50s and 60s
and where do we see
the dialectics of discipline in prisons
today
well guys can go first
well kind of logically
no you need to be in the history
question too no yeah yeah
well i have i have a theory i figured
i'll pose that now i'll pose it now so
the question that i had for derrick
i think you know everybody can comment
on these questions but um
since you're the lawyer among us she's
the only one on stage with the jd um i
would really love for you to reflect on
the relationship between abolition and
the law and as you know well
the law has really served to kind of
facilitate and legitimate uh state
violence against marginalized groups but
it also
has functioned at times as an instrument
of protection and justice so slavery is
abolished we get jim crouch and propose
abolish we get mass criminalization and
i'm wondering what limits and
possibilities the law might offer um
for abolition mm-hmm
all right
the law and the state because that also
came here
i mean do you want me to go first
because because
anybody because you know i'll be
actually i'm not gonna i'll be very
brief okay um
i can't answer the second question which
is kind of cultural forms um but i will
talk about specifically like the
communist party and the sharecroppers
union
because i think if there's a lesson
there
i mean we have to remember that these
movements were crushed
i mean crushed to the point where
there was almost no memory
you know
um and so we have to be prepared
in terms of like the longevity of
movements to recognize that that there's
there's a dialect ebbs and flows
um we wouldn't have had
uh i mean for the sharecroppers union
and for the labor organizing in the
1930s
i mean the truth of the matter is that
it took a lot of courage mobilization a
sense of crisis
but it also took
space that the state created
and we don't always talk about this but
as problematic as a new deal was and as
racist as it was
certain things were products of workers
struggles and this goes back to the
question that you posed
about mutual aid versus the struggle of
state
that they're not necessarily mutually
exclusive
that the struggle to create a national
labor relations
you know
board which of course doesn't affect
sharecroppers because they're not even
covered but that did create space
for unionizing
and for pushing back against companies
that create
um
basically company unions to undermine
the organizing efforts in terms of the
sharecroppers they may not have had
the national labor relations board
behind them
but they had a couple things behind them
the belief
that with all this dynamic organizer
going on that they also need to be out
there organizing
uh even if it meant
engaging in shootouts with police
and then secondly the most amazing thing
this has to do with internationalism
you know the most successful movements
in the 20th century are those that
actually either have connections
beyond borders
or believe they have connections you
don't have to have actually have real
connections but
but what's beautiful about the communist
party in alabama is that
they're like we we are an extension
of the soviet power
and we know and they said this
i mean some people i interviewed said
you know we we knew that when we went on
strike in 1935 if anything were to
happen to us that stalin would send
troops he would send ships across the
atlantic into mobile and troops will
come into alabama and protect us
that's solidarity now that didn't happen
but the belief in it the belief that
somehow you're part of something larger
and that the working class is not a
national class
it's a it's an international class and
this was this has always been
the achilles heel
of american working-class struggles both
as nationalism and nationalism
translates into what white nationalism
it is
black workers workers of color have been
always at the forefront of saying we see
ourselves as the class it's the white
workers that make the mistake of seeing
themselves as a race
and when they see themselves as a race
then they end up joining the wrong side
and this is the this was the message
that the boys taught us and this is the
message of the 1930s because what
happened was
once you had the wind of the federal
government behind your back or belief in
it
all the white folks who
started to realize that wait a second
we don't have any other option but to
organize
and they actually were able to win over
a segment of white working class
um and i think for us in the 21st
century
this is important and i'm not making a
case against quote-unquote identity
politics because i my belief in identity
politics goes back to barbara smith
you know in the combine they have a
different understanding of it
but
i do think it's important not to get
caught up in the silos
and to build power
means to basically you don't have to
you know you don't have to give up
identity but you do have to build power
across the lines of these silos and
sometimes building power means to
mobilize people who at first are against
you
it means mobilizing people who may share
your same interests
politically but they don't know better
what's the point of political education
right is it political education to
basically get people to agree with you
and get them in the room and say yeah
walter rodney you know
or is it to try to build with people who
don't really know
you know
um because the thing is it's not as if
the state
is picking and choosing
who they're trying to bring into their
realm
right so we have to think in those terms
and those are the lessons to me of the
1930s
where are we going chronologically yeah
yeah okay
so i'm i'm all over the place i think
i'm going to interpret the question as
sort of um
a broader like what can we learn from
the struggles of imprisoned people um
because i think that i'm thinking of the
new project too and just what you all
are saying and um i mean for me
not even historically just in this
moment like what what thinking about the
struggles of imprisoned people has
allowed me to do is see everything else
differently so i see the university
differently because i understand its
relationship to
policing and prisons
and that's been useful for me i mean
like when we think about these sort of
campaigns to have cops off campus right
yale can't exist
without police and prisons it's not just
about eradicating
police from
the the campus right like
the
only way that yale can operate through
dispossession
through incarceration through
imprisonment through
through land seizure is through police
and prisons so
like when you read george jackson
talking about fascism yeah yes reform
right
it's like
people don't think we're living in a
fascist police state
but it's because you don't feel the
fascist police state the way
that lawrence feels it the way that
stevie feels it they would think it's
ridiculous to say we are not living in a
fascist police state
stevie can't receive his writings
he writes things that are published in
the so-called free world that he can
then not receive back
that's fascism
but it's not fascism if we don't feel it
right that's what we think
um
i
i talk about collective dreaming this
project that i'm writing that robin and
derek were so gracious to read i try to
share my writings on martin sostre who's
this you know revolutionary anarchist
political prisoner with people inside
they can't read it
so there's all this kind of like
you know talk about censorship and
anti-crt and book bannings like it's
happening every day i promise you if you
are a politicized prisoner
every
thing you do
is is mediated through the state
through fascism
so i think what's valuable about
not just studying these struggles but
being in solidarity with and in
community with people is you're able to
understand
the way that all these unseen forces of
criminalization and incarceration are
shaping
this you know in a way that you wouldn't
understand otherwise
i don't know if i answered your question
at all
dialectic that's a great answer okay no
it's important it's important i'm just
thinking about so much about what even
what even starts so abolition and the
law
the law is kind of trash i don't know i
don't i'm trying to figure out what's
the worst the best way to even even
start is anyone in law school or want to
go to law school
or walk past the law school
there are some but they're not raising
their hands oh okay yeah i don't know
it's so interesting um
where do you start with this so are you
asking if they're compatible they're
relationship to each other i'm just
wondering like how you see i mean
because you're you're abolition i mean
and you you have a law degree you are a
lawyer so like what are you like how can
the law be a tool or is it just trash i
mean maybe it's just trash well yeah
well some trash is useful that's why we
go oh let me get this out
i wish i hadn't thrifted that shirt so
it's complicated yes so what what can i
say i think that
yes i had i've
we sometimes we talk about
politicization as like an event that
happens in our lives and then we're like
whoa but no people are constantly
experiencing different levels of being
politicized when we're introducing
different you know politics and so i was
politicizing abolition mostly in law
school after i already entered right so
you know i talk about you know the book
that michael brown was killed about five
minutes from my house about three weeks
before i started law school and so i
drove from st louis to cambridge trying
to figure out how to wrap my head around
the movement that was happening outside
and then you go to class and then you
have professors who don't talk about it
and then you spend a year in dena
students offices crying so they can send
an email to acknowledge how violent and
painful this is to try to study for
exams while there are dead bodies going
viral on social media so that that was
like
what is going on like why why am i
learning about this
at this particular moment
i think what was interesting when i told
you all when i came back and i asked the
students i was organizing with there
were a lot of us there were maybe like a
hundred students who were actively
engaged on a daily basis of trying to
figure out how to connect what we were
learning to what was happening outside
when i said hey y'all i think that we
should probably do political education
because i don't think a diversity office
is going to help change this i don't
think that hiring a critical race
theorist is going to actually
fundamentally shake up the things that
we're fighting for um i think that we
should like read and study and think
critically about what we're trying to
accomplish especially since we're going
to be future lawyers
and after lots of tense debates our
movement split
now how at least half of us left oh half
of that group left and they were like
y'all just want to sit around and read
and like affirm each other about how
right you are y'all not trying to
actually win or change harvard so we're
going to leave and the rest of us
entered into a student occupation for
the next year and a half um so much so i
graduated five years ago
and people still who go to hls call the
space we occupy belinda hall like that
is what we renamed and reclaim that
space which i think is
somewhat noteworthy but what was so
beautiful about belinda hall and us
going through our political education
process it became the only space on
campus where anyone could teach or take
a class it didn't matter if you were a
dining services worker it didn't matter
if you were a janitor it mattered if
you're a clinical faculty you could take
you can teach or take a class right it's
where organizers from boston will come
in and do and train us on organizing
techniques right it was it was a place
where anyone could come and eat is where
we you know said we don't want police
here i mean police were showing up to
our visuals like the bosses the black
lawsuit association we would have like
candles and people were crying it would
be police so when you said that places
like yale don't exist without the police
it's sort of a concrete thing and so to
me it's not always like what about the
murders or what about the rapist that's
not why police primarily exist they they
exist to manage inequality and protect
borders in intro like internal borders
external borders right so
there are people who struggle with that
question so much elizabeth about
you know how do i grapple with these new
sets of understanding that i have about
the world and my role in it and then
reconcile that with becoming a lawyer
and there were people who gave up their
firm jobs you know people who gave up
two hundred thousand dollars a year to
pay back their student debt and became
public defenders or entered into public
service work there were some people who
said i can't be a lawyer i can't
reconcile this and there are label
organizers still right now and so people
grapple with it in a lot of different
ways i told i mean robin knows this
every year i have a crisis i'm like
should i be in a phd program so people
were struggling with like can i actually
be a lawyer i think the reason why i
chose to
study for that horrible thing called the
bar exam
um and then become a lawyer because i
knew that there were people in saint
louis who were figuring out how to put
pressure on the
ferguson police department through this
litigation effort with the department of
justice called a consent decree and
being a lawyer was one way that i could
help them and i already took out the
debt so like you know what like i'm
gonna have to pay back over a hundred
thousand dollars anyway might as well
try it out a little bit and so that's
that's sort of what happened and i was i
felt very lucky and very fortunate to be
able to do that and so can it be a tool
absolutely and if you're a lawyer you
can get people out of jail you can help
people litigate you can
you know do what i do which is
those things but also help think about
policy in a particular way to put your
help gets bills drafted right so i think
that's important
i think that people in our community do
those things as well who are not lawyers
there's people who do participatory
defense they're people who represent
themselves and get people out of jail i
mean the law is intentionally written in
particular language so that people who
take out hundreds of thousands of
student loan debt can articulate that
and then make good on it so it's really
good job security right but i'm always
inspired when i watch
community based organizations do court
watching they're not those people are
not lawyers and what do they do every
monday in kansas city you have tenants
who go and watch eviction court and
because of their presence because of
their organizing they put pressure on
the judge to delay or stop evictions
you don't need a law degree to do that
right so i didn't know that before i
went to law school but the more that i
lawyer the more that i organize the more
that i write the more that i am in the
social movement i learn how people
decide to use the law but more
importantly how to use their presence
and their organizing as tactics to
manipulate the law as a non-reformist
reform something that doesn't give it
more power and more legitimacy but
actually it's trying to decrease the
violence or at least mitigate what it's
doing in the world so i think that's
important and it's the answer i'm
excited to give which is different than
a question i'm usually asked which is
can i be an abolitionist and a lawyer
right that's the question i feel like
i'm asked the most at like at school say
can i can i do these things i was like
well
i don't know i think again more
important than you identifying as an
abolitionist lawyer is that you try to
be a part of a political organization
and lawyer and try to figure out if you
can use your skills towards that broader
movement and what's so fascinating the
work that i do in that capacity is not
my lowering work and i don't get paid
for it right i don't get paid to like be
on phone calls for 15 hours a week
thinking about student debt cancellation
with dream defenders that's not i didn't
go to harvard law school in order to do
that but that's something that's
important to me because i know that once
we figure out how to make sure that we
can you know cancel and abolish all
kinds of debts fight for universal
health care fight for free education it
increases agency for people to live the
kind of lives that we want to live and
we deserve it and so
yeah
yeah
i mean yeah i mean i think everyone as
panel will know that the way that so
many of our hopes and dreams especially
given the professionalization pushing
like the 80s and 90s that if you want to
go do good in the world to channel that
through a career through like a specific
career like you know it's like yeah like
go do this thing and the right's not
doing that right the right's not doing
that you know the you i know you said
earlier um
what did you just say it reminded me of
this that essentially the doors of white
supremacy are always open right but at
any moment it's kind of like i'm serious
at any moment if you want to go oh yeah
when you're talking about the white
workers
um at any moment if you want to join a
white supremacist organization you can
like you can you can go
do this
it's not i mean you obviously become a
cop or into the military or enter any
one of these other positions but they
their ability that's grass was
organizing right they're doing this is
stuff they're doing also in their spare
time and so sometimes i'm nervous that
people who care about freedom and
justice think that they can only do that
through a specific career and it's like
no you need to be a part of a political
organization or figure out how to
support what that's how we build it's
the same movements for the long term and
i'm nervous about the decline of that
especially as i'm as i look at what's
happening with progressives in the left
it's like everyone is doing this through
their policy job and no one's doing this
through political struggle and even
though we hear 20 million people were
pouring to the streets for a protest
that's cool but 20 million people did
not get absorbed into organizations
20 million people are not outside the
white house when biden says i'm going to
keep choosing to refund the police 20
million people are not outside of rikers
saying let these people out because
they're dying rapidly and so that energy
that we get excited about when we get
those glimpses that gets called a
movement but movements require so much
more sustainability and organizing than
those moments and so we need people and
uh now i'm like this is like all to call
like we need people to join
organizations or at least to figure out
how to support them so we can fight and
build something much more sustainable
thank you thank you all for that and
thanks for that
i mean
and i think too you know you kind of
ended on a historical lesson because
that's what we see that's what sustained
the that's what's the same the freedom
movement historically you know it's been
organizing it's been sustaining it it's
you know been not just mass
mobilizations okay so i want to i have a
million more questions but we're running
out of time so i really want to open it
up to everyone else um so please start
coming down to the microphones to ask
questions and while you do that i'm
gonna um pose one
from online from polly and then kind of
tack one of my own questions onto it so
polly asked
how can we who have lived our entire
lives with an empire create live into
political relationships that don't
replicate oppressive patterns and um i
know that's a really really important
very broad question i would also kind of
based on where the conversation is
headed
invite you to also reflect on
what universities and what university
communities can and should do i mean you
know we're here at el university which
um just had an endowment over the past
year go up by 10 billion dollars um and
yet it gets the people of new haven
basically subsidized yale at 160 million
dollars a year
um and 34 of the
kids in new haven um are at or below the
poverty level so
so how do we how do how can we think
about
abolishing structures that we are very
much um tied to and and within
from me and polly
well i think the last thing you said was
the answer was in the question
i mean you know we have just just to
talk about yell this is this is an old
issue and of course yale's not unique
um
but you have these land-grant
institutions that don't pay taxes
that you know where there's a
intense union struggle going on all the
time for living wage
um
and i'm at a
and i teach at a school where the
basketball coach uh
you know
makes way more money than anyone else
you know um
and so there's some basic things like
you know if you think about
you know
reparations
and decolonization take these two themes
reparations would mean that those
institutions like yale that have been
exploiting
people on stolen land
for
three centuries
owe something
and so you know and and if you include
everything that they've been able to
extract
and figure out a way to sort of take
that and give it back it's one thing i
mean this may be a legal regime for that
but decolonization is another thing you
know
um
in terms of the question about how do
you not replicate oppressive
systems
something as basic as
you know fighting for indigenous
sovereignty
can change
a lot of things in terms of not just the
environment
but in terms of
working condition housing
you know
if because i'd much rather be under
sovereign rule of indigenous peoples
than i would under the united states
you know
um so these are all opportunities that
basically means each one of those things
means two things
it means
the massive redistribution of wealth and
resources that have been extracted and
stolen
and two it means
some complete transformation of
governance
and you know that may seem like pie in
the sky
but there's precedent for that you know
i know
why y'all looking at me i don't know
well
i'm just kidding well i
what can
people be doing at the university well i
think i want to stay organized like we
need people to organize i think it's
very exciting when i see students and
faculty and staff organized together
another major lesson i learned in south
africa was just the students and the
staff struggle were united for
intentional reasons because the staff
were in precarious position
um they were
being shifted to become a contractual
laborers which means that they lost
health care and tuition and benefits and
all the things they really fight for
fought for to be a part of the
university so those struggles are so
important it makes me think about
the early formations of the first black
studies programs you know in the 60s
those black student organizations that
were forming they weren't forming like
for students anyone could kind of come
and be a part of them you know when they
took over campus san francisco state
university those students they went like
the black students and staff they went
into the admission offices and admitted
black students because the university
wouldn't admit black students right it's
like this is the context sometimes i'm
nervous that because we don't think
about the length that people went
through for political struggle the
possibilities seem like much more
shallow
i think it would be what would it look
like for students here to call for a
moratorium just a moratorium just to say
hey let's stop for a second let's pause
an expansion of yale in new haven it's a
very that's a low-hanging fruit that's
not even all the way to the economy is
like hey
no more yesterday when i was leaving the
event last night i got into uber ride
and the driver was playing t-pain which
was really nice it was i felt warm and
welcomed i was like okay this is like
this is good and i just started asking
her questions about what it's like being
in new haven and she said well all my
friends are leaving because we can't
afford to live no more i was like where
are they moving to she didn't she said
new york she didn't say dc she said
north carolina south carolina and
georgia
i said is it because of the cost of
living that people like keep going
further and further and she said yeah
she said you can't live around here and
i was like why not she said you know she
i think she would just i think she was
probably a police officer or a security
guard she had her uniform
she said i don't know you know i hear
activists be using words like
gentrification but
i i i didn't know what gentrification
was but in my entire life i knew that it
was happening
right and i was like oh you gotta join
an organization then i just started
doing my little organization with her
too
she was like you know maybe that's not
like my thing but people are going to
fight for it but yeah let's just go win
yo let's just going and i was like well
you still got to try you know we still
got to try so when i see students trying
to do that student staff faculty you
know there are students right now who
are student harvard over their endowment
because it's
investing in prisons and things that
contribute to fossil fuels i think
that's exciting i think the cops off
campus initiative i think that's pretty
exciting i think people who are doing
inside outside programs where people are
incarcerated i think that's important um
i think yeah i think that that's all
enough i think i mean i don't think
that's enough i think that was a good
start but i really do think it's gonna
depend on what inspires you to get
activated and doing that political
education with other people to figure
out okay what's the long-term goal uh
and say this really quickly but
gary i keep thinking what you say you
know
yale wouldn't be yale and before we
split that student group i was talking
about when we were reconfiguring our
demands and we said you know we need to
rethink our admissions policy
you know
we need to rethink tuition all this
stuff and one of the students said well
would this even be harvard if we had
open admissions and had such a fear of
losing status when we were fighting for
again very low hanging fruit we wanted
the shield of harvard law to change
because it belonged to a family that
bequeathed money to start harvard law
school that got that money because he
was a slaver right you know fled during
the revolutionary war but gave the money
to harvard law school and when people
when we fought to even get a shield
change a picture that wasn't even that
cute it wasn't even that cute but there
were a lot
including black alum who said oh
is my degree gonna mean the same thing
is my diploma gonna mean the same thing
if you guys get a new shoe whoa whoa
whoa come on and then our professors
what did they say
well if we you know want to you know
change the shield then if you carry that
line on through we're just going to
change all the symbols in the united
states
i said is that a critique or a plan
because that's our plan i said yeah it
might not be you know what i said sounds
good i was like you trying to come to
the meeting on thursday right so like
there's a deep fear of loss and that
deep fear of loss is being conflated
with erasure and protecting history and
we have to say no this is decolonization
and we have to figure out how to build
more you know systemic movement to name
that we can affirm the loss for some
people we can't say just because you're
afraid of losing status that this is not
worth the fight
that's right
let's take a question from the audience
from nassar
student in my afm survey class thank you
for being the first
[Laughter]
peace family um so yeah nasser i'm in uh
professor hinton's class
and um you know i really enjoyed the
panel thank you for coming and god too
but um you know
um
i'm i'm like kind of involved with like
i was like a community organizer for
black lives matter paterson and we're
really like heavily involved with like
the mutual aid that you guys talking
about you know um we're very thankful
but like we every friday we like go out
in the community right police ridden
this is
mass incarceration just the violence is
there and you know in giving it's much
more than giving food it's it's also
about like telling stories and and and
joy and laughter right and so
it really is like a movement of love
at the basis
which is at the center for my opinion of
the political education that we're
getting at
but um you know maybe in your
experiences both like research and on
the streets activism like what do you
think the role is and the importance of
love um and building that in the
abolitionist movement
yeah i mean it's at the center i think
is what i mean that's like robin's
article that i mentioned earlier um you
know
love study struggle um
and i just think
that love is
is related to trust
and relationships which are
at the core of
struggle and organizing um
and i think
another component maybe that i'll just
push out there
that's related to love is about
commitment and i don't mean commitment
to a set of principles but a commitment
to people just to be around and to not
you know dip in and dip out that you
have to maintain lifelong relationships
with people and that love can sound
really good
and it can also be really hard
right and we think about how hard love
is in our
families or our
you know intimate relationships but
political
love for long periods of time can be
really hard i mean people hurt each
other
people betray each other
so i think
if that's not at the core of the
organizing that we do it can fall apart
really fast and there's that energy when
you start organizing and you feel like
there's love and all this stuff and it
can get really
tough fast i think once that
once you enter a kind of
period of maturity right
and
you know i would also add this there's
three kinds of love there's arrows which
we sometimes conflate with love there's
philia which is friendship and then
there's agape
and
so when i talk about love and i think a
lot of us talk about love we're thinking
in terms of agape which dr king
you know is you know drawing people like
paul tillich
calls the constant relentless struggle
to make community
and no distinction between friend and
enemy
that's the hardest thing
now we may know who what forces were
raid against
and that's different
but the idea is that you try to create a
community that is completely inclusive
and even the people that you don't agree
with
you pull them in not for consensus
because not about consensus it's about
constant struggle to make community
which means you debate you struggle you
fight you critique until you could come
to a place
of
of agreement
which we know is always temporary so
just like gary was saying it's very very
hard to do but you can't there's no such
thing as a movement without love
i mean the irony is that even the clan
they operate on a basis of a really
demonic
kind of love
you know
and it's about it's it's not even on the
map that kind of love but it's vicious
you know
yeah i agree i agree um
it's
definitely been what robin just said
about that constant struggle to build
community and a better society for the
people who may even disagree with you or
who may hate you i mean i dislike you
it's
it's yes it's hard so much so i actually
the chapter 4 in the book is called love
and abolition for that reason because i
care deeply about what that struggle
takes and i try to show like this is
this is where i talk about that split in
the student movement and how hard that
was it's where i talk about representing
a client that i had who was very very
racist toward me and toward other people
right i had to stand next to this person
in court and vigorously defend that
person right it's where
i talk about the
black reconstruction
and how
you know the boy sort of focuses on
abolitionists primarily why abolitionism
in the critique of du bois for missing
out the deep revolutionary love and
practices that black insurrectionists
did to like flee and like build
communities in the in the face of white
supremacist violence so i think love has
a central place and i hope my comments
about me to a
like i'm hearing what you're saying i'm
not anti-mutual
i am very pro mutual a i heart mutually
very very different
in the book i affirm each way and i
think is very very important i think in
my earlier comments what i was saying is
that i'm nervous that
the the bro there's a shift i'm
experiencing among like my peers and
people who are actually younger than me
to mutual aid out of desperation and
pessimism which is not the same as
shifting to it out of love i have a lot
of love for blm patterson i think that's
zelly the whole crew i think y'all doing
exactly i know i know see i think that
work is very important that free
refrigerators where people can come get
food i get it i know we have to keep
doing that i don't think zelly and
everyone there is organizing from that
place right but i'm nervous about that
becoming a widespread thing that's all
thank you you ain't no i knew did you i
know you look
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
surprised
hello everyone um hi i have a question
from a comrade inside actually oh great
um i don't know if the mic is on oh is
it not okay
can you oh yeah maybe it turned off
i'm just thinking for the people online
too
yeah
i'm i'm worth the technology
okay
sorry
okay all right
okay is this yeah that's much better wow
amazing okay thank you um hi everyone i
have a question from a comrade inside i
mean i also have a question of my own
but i think this is like more important
um
so if y'all could just kind of speak
slowly when you answer it we're going to
try to kind of write down your response
that would be really helpful
so this is technically for derek i think
it can work for anyone it says hello
dereka parnell
i'm a prisoner in texas and i received a
copy of your book through no name books
in la i became politicized in 2017
through contact with black and pink who
you mentioned in your book it's been my
observation that the abolition community
is made up of a vast number of diverse
collectives and i was wondering if you
had any suggestions as to how these
various collectives can communicate with
each other and become aware of each
other so we can organize as a whole
so cool
[Music]
that's a well i'm at least familiar with
the collections and coalitions among
abolitionist organizations is how
actually i came to learn about a lot of
abolished organizations because i'm i'm
a part of groups and collectives and
convenings where people are trying to
figure out how to align our work and so
those aren't typically broadcast or
public but they happen they happen
regularly the last one i actually
organized was in 2000
2020 was the last thing i did before the
pandemic and it was a convening on
police abolition and we had no idea that
seven months later defund the police
would be the primary demand from the
streets we we just didn't know because
this was you know it was actually that
week was the weekend kobe bryant died
like i knew that weekend was so
transformational and so memorable for
lots of different reasons but
in that convening there were maybe there
were dozens of organizations there maybe
a hundred people who were trying to
figure out our lines of difference and
how to build coalition i know critical
resistance has had convenience of people
doing abolitionist work moomi was also
incredible one of the last
abolitionist convenings that i attended
um i i think that what's
that
i don't know if the person was asking
that question is asking for something
that feels like a united front
you know
yeah i want to say that i think any of
those number of people who are right
about in the book
they know about the other stuff that's
going on and so i don't know if it means
that it needs to be advertised better
but most of those convenience is except
for the public one like you did are
strategy convenience we're trying to
figure out like okay when people ask
like what about the murders and what
about sexual violence what's the work
that's happening in communities to
disrupt that and to help minimize that
like what are you guys doing in your
neighborhood how can we practice that in
our neighborhood so
that is happening fortunately i i would
assume that a lot of these people know i
think that the thing i'm actually
concerned about is whether
the
the prison police abolition folks are
actually missing out on like the
socialism stuff there's like a there's
like dsa over here and like abolitionist
organizations over there and they're
like
sunrise is like in the middle so there's
like all these interesting important
organizations that are coming up and i'm
nervous that their politics are sort of
insular wrapped around their particular
thing and so i've met yeah i've met
abolitionists people who claim that
abolitionist and still hold on to
capitalism i've met socialists who are
staunch anti-abolitionists so
trying to like get people together think
through our class analyses and our
colonial analyses is i think that work
has to do a lot more
i can give this to you so you don't have
to try to type it all right now um and
then i can also make some
recommendations of where that person can
start
yeah could i just add two well one i i
think we're going to have a transcript
of this so we can also that will be
much easier
um
and
um to this question about
i mean this is sort of like a call to
action again like from the front and
some tangible ways to get involved i
think
so much of the work
that has to be done across walls right
is between us and people inside but then
there's this other barrier
to i think collective dreaming and
organizing which is people inside
between right and like the the the
gender segregation that happens in
prisons i mean the organizing that
happens in different prisons is is
different
and so one of the things that we've been
trying to do with study and struggle is
really
act as facilitators outside so people
inside can share
organizing with each other so that's
part of
why we produce transcripts and send them
inside and have panels with incarcerated
people from different states and then
produce a transcript of that to send to
other states
and this is not new work i mean i don't
know if folks are familiar with yuri
kochiyama
but
i've been talking to political prisoners
from that era and they talk about
writing people
inside and i was like oh dude and back
in the day you could write to people
inside and they were like no i wrote to
yuri and then she sent you know so
there's these interlocutors outside and
it's i'm not i mean this is not sexy
work this is
painstaking unseen labor
but to be the people who are
facilitating those
relationships because then people inside
don't have to constantly in in isolation
from one another
invent
and reinvent these things i just think
so much of what
the prison is doing is is
that isolation it's not just a
geographic separation it's a it's a
barrier to the collective knowledge that
we all have can i give one quick example
about that just to make it very very
clear in many states if not all states
if you try to start a petition you can
get into solitary confinement and a
petition is anything that has more than
one signature and so there's like
organizations like fight toxic prisons
who work with people who are inside to
do like one signature petitions because
that's how they have to like build
momentum for their cause like in matt
like when you talk about fascism inside
prisons
you if you try to do something as simple
as get two three ten signatures try to
organize your wing you're trying to
start it right you're trying to inside
the right so this is the importance of i
just want to illustrate that because
that to me is one of the examples that
make it so bright
and can i say one more thing
so much of the work we do outside is
online exclusively
people inside have no
way of accessing that which is obvious
to say but to the extent that you can
create a sort of printable
version of that for people like i
constantly just find myself emailing
people and like was there a transcript
is there a pdf i'm like copying pasting
websites into word documents and sending
them so i just think we need to be
cognizant of
how that is a barrier for people who are
organizing
thank you so much for that so thank you
for that question
do you want to did you want to ask your
question okay okay all right cool thanks
mom
okay my okay this is this is on right
okay cool all right okay my other
question is that
i think there's a lot of appreciable
tension and movement work on between
legal and extra legal action i guess
this is kind of pushing a little bit
more on the question that you asked
previously um
i think a lot of folks inside sometimes
do emphasize kind of legal action just
for i don't know small things like i
don't want to cut my hair and things
like that like in this vein
how would you define non-reformist
reforms and what place of any do you
think they have in movement work
[Music]
can you use the term you don't wanna
no you're writing about this right now
this is so good
about non-performance performance no i'm
not about using it but yeah yeah
okay so i'll take i mean something right
yeah let me throw this question in there
too from from online just because we're
running out of time um
and and i think it's on a related point
from that question and just the
discussion in general um
and it comes from um
someone been off online and it says
comrades inside are often struggling to
survive the imminent threats and slow
death of prison how do we bridge the gap
between survival and politics
and then this is another one i'm just
going to throw out thrown a lot out
there alternatively would y'all mind
speaking a bit about the dialectic
between the struggle to survive
incarceration and the development of the
abolitionist movement
i see what you did there
um okay i'll take a piece okay okay so
um
yeah i mean i think um
this get this gets back to the question
about law and abolition in a way
and it's just that
so dereko very carefully crafted the
difference between the use of law
and being a lawyer
and an abolitionist like a vocational
sort of careerist
um
version versus the tool of law and i
think that
goes for a lot of different things which
is that i don't think we can afford to
leave any tools on the table
right like these are all
potentially
subversive tools if used appropriately
and that doesn't mean that they're not
dangerous tools that can
wind up being
reforms um and therefore you know
fascist but
um
yeah i mean i'm writing about a person
who is a revolutionary anarchist and a
jailhouse lawyer and used constitutional
law
to
um
you know to mitigate the circumstances
that he was organizing i mean he was at
one point in solitary confinement
unable to communicate with a single
person besides his lawyer so there the
law is
both the sort of only gateway to the
outside world
and he knew
how to write a writ that wound up in
constance baker motley's court and got
him out of solitary so he could do other
things like write a revolutionary
newspaper and organize a chapter of the
black panther party
so it's it's i think that kind of
relationship of you know i mean he
wasn't
thinking like this constitution that's
so sacrosanct will
abolish the state
but that that was a
that was basically the only tool
available to him really so i think
that's my answer to that question
oh no go ahead no you you know more than
me well i'm only going to say one thing
about the law which may not answer the
question but
just
because you know i've been i'm writing
something on matulou shakur right now
and trying desperately to get him out
and matulou has been in prison for a
long time precisely because
when he got locked up in 1986
he
and others made the case
that they're prisoners of war
in other words they turn to
international law international courts
in geneva conventions and that's so the
federal courts they hate that the judge
hates that and so
his his
mandatory um
uh parole had passed
and he's still locked up had coveted
still locked up
so i think that there's something to say
just to for those of you interested to
look at international law
to look at that as an option to look at
what it means to be a prisoner of war
you know trying to fight for justice and
that there's certain protections that
prisons of war is supposed to have
in the united states or elsewhere so
that's just one
area of the law we don't always think
about you know that's not necessarily
reformist reform but
derek knows more than me
what was the part of the last question
online
uh bridge to the gap
yeah how did we get between survival and
politics and um
yeah we'll just say that well wait no
what was the second part because that
was the second part was um would you all
mind speaking a bit about the dialectic
between the struggle to survive
incarceration and the development of the
abolitionist movement
yes so i was a similar point came up
earlier today in the conversation i was
having about abolition and
it the way that the person sort of
framed it it was as if the abolitionists
are like outside talking about abolition
doing abolitionist organizing and there
are people who are incarcerated dealing
with the real realities of like the
prison and they
you know they don't have time for like
the abolitionist stuff outside because
you know they need access to food they
need access to water they all all of
this they they're experiencing
overcrowding and what i
how can i say this the bridge is there
like the the work comes from that bridge
right because
most of the people at least the the
tradition i hope that i belong to that i
see myself belong to the the for 40
years at least of writings and
organizing around the prison industrial
complex so much of that direction has
come from the people inside it's like
you know but for their organizing their
rebellions their uprisings i think that
has given rise to the prison abolition
movement outside of prisons right and so
you're talking about angela davis
speaking in 1994
and you know speaking from someone who
was a once a political prisoner right so
that it's it's not like how do we get
this to like reach each other but so
much of that that survivor work
that risk taking that then informs the
struggle that takes place outside and i
want to emphasize to emphasize that so
so so much because we're in an era where
there's this thing around deference
politics like you defer the people who
are directly impacted right but the
people who they want you to defer to who
are directly impacted or people who they
decide and usually people who want to
maintain the power of
prisons right i i've never seen a
philanthropy cop conferences
abolitionists directly impacted people
you know or survivors of the type of
survivors that people in the mainstream
choose to uplift this we need to be
listening to these kinds of black women
but then i have black women abolitionist
survivors right and so well i think
what's important for us to always name
and to explain is that so much of our
grassroots organizing so much of what
makes it into the halls at harvard and
to yale has first been theorized and
organized around people who experience
the oppression right
that is true of radical politics
that is very very very very true and we
must not forget that so when i hear
critiques of abolition being an academic
exercise i was like oh wait wait wait
wait wait like let's go back 40 years
ago before the uprisings in 2020. unless
let's read the works of people look at
the demands of prisoners doing these
rebellions yes they were asking for you
know um more freedoms they were also
asking to be free all right they were
asking for a better food and a right to
health care because they want to die and
suffer until they're released right but
they also demanded to close prisons nas
didn't say you know if i ruled the world
you know i would free all non-violent
offend offenders
not in my version
i didn't hear that verse he said i free
all my sons oh oh you know
take them out of attica send them to
africa that's the version i heard you
know so it's like it's it's so much you
know you asked about culture earlier
it's so much in our culture because
again we learned that based on our
experiences and so it doesn't make us
experts hopefully just helps keep us
within that tradition
yeah yeah and by the way the anti-clan
movement started in prison you know that
right
the anti-clan movement in the 1980s
began in prison with prisoners who are
fighting the clan who were hired as
guards and wardens
and we forget that we think that somehow
all these movements are on outside in
that you know on the inside people are
not fighting those two invites this is a
perfect example
go for it yeah
um
hello uh thank you so much for
um all being here i you know when i
heard that there was a a panel with all
of you on it i was like how do you get
this many like of the people who i who i
admire in the their fields of
scholarship onto
one one desk
um
but
you know i was really interested
actually and i feel like it's been a
theme throughout everything that that
you all have said
at the beginning um both
well sorry what was the name of the
first of the the two people inside that
you um oh lawrence
yeah where where sort of lawrence was
saying look you know mutual aid is great
and all but but we're not you know we
also have to keep in mind sort of
fighting to actually end these
structures
um
and you know and i
i feel like there's a disconnect that i
i see because i
i grew up fairly politicized but i
became an organizer during the the
rebellions around you know mike mike
brown and um
eric garner in new york
and
i feel like ever since that moment i've
just seen a disconnect between like both
what happens in like
organizing spaces and in you know
movement spaces of like protest and then
an even bigger disconnect between what
happens in like these spaces
and what's happening in the in the
streets
and you know i i
like i feel like it's so poignant in in
so many places like you know i don't
want to go into details but i've seen
people who call themselves organizers
like fighting to control the the sort of
in their eyes destructive you know like
like you know
like errant like destructive impulses of
like people who are just like okay these
cops are like
screwing with us every day i have
friends inside i want to like burn this
police station to the ground and they're
like no don't do that we're nonviolent
right and obviously like this is an
exaggeration of what some people
are on you know and then you get to to
hear and i think that like
you you think about the difference
between the like uprisings in in like at
mizu that happened in 2015 and what
happened here is like when at mizu the
first thing they were talking about was
their connections to ferguson because it
was so close and here like
you tried to mention police brutality
and everyone was like you're gonna
destroy our movement
um and like muddy the waters and so i
guess like
in terms of both of these kinds of
of disconnects i do think that there is
a really important role of those of us
who maybe have put a lot of
you know pre you know premium on you
know who have existed in a lot of these
spaces
um
in in movement
but i guess i wonder how do you
build
those kinds of long-term
um sort of movements to like destroy
these systems
that that you're talking about how do
you how do you sort of bridge those
those gaps because you know what you
were saying earlier about like okay you
have 12 million people out in the
streets but you don't see them in front
of the white house i think that the flip
side of that right is that everybody is
like oh well what you're doing is just
like spontaneous you got to get
organized and then people are like okay
so what do i do to get organized they're
like follow us on instagram you know
come out to campaign for this politician
and they're like well that's not what we
want we were here to destroy the police
and so i guess like
obviously you know i know that a lot
this is not to say this radical work
isn't happening and i'm not asking for
you know i'm sure there are plenty of
people in this room who know about some
of this work and i'm not asking to henry
box brown anyone
um but i guess like if you have some
sort of in the perhaps slightly more
abstract like
how to actually create the culture of
sort of destruction of policing in
prisons and take those cues from from
inside where people are saying
you know abolition nothing less
and you have
one minute sorry the answer those that
answer that big question one minute one
minute a minute
i'm not going to answer the question but
i will say that everything that you just
described
is old
no no i'm saying it's not new that's not
a critique what i'm saying is that this
has been you go back to mass
mobilizations versus what snake is doing
in mississippi you count the number of
people who are organizing the snake it's
very small you count the people who show
up in washington
d.c on august you know 28th it's large
you think about all the divisions
sometimes with divisions around social
economic issues some of those divisions
around anti-communism
you know so
it's like the difference of course is
social media and other strategies but
i'm saying this is the age-old issue and
i'm sure that both garrett and derek
have some solutions to that age audition
i i'll just say no i'll just say briefly
i do think that to kind of the point
that derek shared earlier about
the
the disagreement or the sort of lack of
clarity around what we mean by abolition
like we do want a mass movement but i
think we do need to clarify i mean
that's why i
really take the task of defining
abolition seriously as a you know a
worthy because i think
you know like
are we talking about abolishing the
state
and a lot of people are not talking
about abolishing the state but then how
do we imagine
a state existing without police and
prisons like i don't think that could
exist but people clearly do oh there's
an anarchist this is new i don't know
um
no so i just think i think we need more
space to really hash out
what we're talking about like are we
talking about um
abolition and capitalism i didn't know
we were talking about that you know so
um
but no i don't think it's a thing to be
resolved as much a contradiction to be
lived
all right derek how you have the last
word last word oh jesus okay so i
i agree with a big part of your
assessment i wrote about this actually
in january that i'm nervous that
with the rise of social media what has
happened with online organizing is that
we have
organizers perhaps inadvertently have
created a like share subscribe culture
and that's how people can get involved
in the movement which is very very
different than come to this meeting sit
here for three hours to like do an
orientation can you offer this as a
sacrifice of your time and your labor
enough your talent so i think that
organizers are trying to figure out how
to do mass absorption
with the rise of the internet and i
think it's very challenging
i've seen and constantly working through
those challenges i think similar also to
what i was saying earlier about people
channeling our um
our like hopes and dreams into like
specific korean [ __ ] on the left i'm
very nervous about that i think a
similar thing has happened too around
how do we effectuate change and so in
the long time ago you would see like
these vibrant movements to shut things
down and use all tactics from
revolutionary violence to the law to
figure it out now when something happens
everyone gives money to the aclu right
wouldn't the aclu become like the front
line no shade to the atl you like not
really like no shade to aclu but they
become like i don't know the che guevara
like i moved it's so wild i'm like every
time there's a crisis like we're gonna
take them to court and then people give
money for them to go to court and it's
like yeah we need to go to court but we
also need much more like mass
mobilizations and people entering to
organizations and finding political
homes to figure out how to answer these
questions and so i'm attracted to
organizations like dissenters who is
trying to build a youth movement to end
militarism you know who's fighting to
keep rotc's off of campuses who's
fighting against the 1033 transfer
program who's trying to do deep
political organizing around these issues
and so
we have those examples that exist
and they're engaging in lots of
different tactics and trying to figure
out how to absorb people to then
effectuate that right and so i think the
more we realize the terrain where people
now are just donating to a non-profit or
people in the past who didn't have
political representation that looked
like that so now you think you're
fighting a white supremacist structure
that's keeping black people or women out
and now we have more the most amount of
diverse representation three people are
still being killed today by the police
more than a million black people are
still locked up black women still have
wealth of five dollars like so the
political representation through
diversity isn't answered because who was
it like fred hampton said we were saying
white when we should have been saying
capitalists all right we were our
critiques were like being lost in the
wrong places and so i think that we
absolutely need political homes we need
organizations to really think about the
traditions that get people off of line
and into seats and that's very hard but
it's something we just have to figure
out and do
please join me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all for just an incredible and
eye-opening discussion
[Applause]